while flood control is helping there are
still plenty of projects in the works
for certain areas we go now to sally
jaramillo my colleague she shows us how
far we've come
and what's in store for the future good
evening sally
[Music]
ted you and i both know yesterday's
storms brought a whole lot of water
especially to the southern highlands
park
water running through this walking trail
aaron f with the regional flood control
district tells me there are signs
showing this is a dual use drainage
recreation facility
and can flood reminding you to stay away
during a storm as there are still
drainage issues in this area
we know to take them pretty seriously
just because we're from here we've had
two straight years of non-soon and now
she's back to normal habits aaron neff
with the regional flood control district
vividly recalls two major flooding
events in southern nevada
caesar's palace in july of 1975 and the
flood devastation in 1999
at the miracle mile mobile home park
since we've been created in the late
1980s
we have built 667 miles
of channels and storm drains we've built
102 detention bases
while we come a long way over the years
nev says we have more to accomplish
only 75 percent of the overall master
plan to control flooding
is complete currently we have a 10-year
construction plan
just approved in june to spend 800
million dollars on
improvements this includes uh 12
new detention basins it includes 25
i'm sorry 75 miles of channel they will
also go back into established areas of
central las vegas for upgrades
in the growing southern highlands area
there are still some drainage concerns
that will be fixed in the coming years
it's a pretty bad flood area but we've
heard for years are going to be fixing
everything and it seems like there's
more and more work to do every year
with chances of storms this week as
we've been seeing it is a good reminder
for those new to las vegas to be careful
if you see areas with a lot of water
and it's also a good reminder for those
who have lived here for quite some time
now you know the slogan
turn around don't drown reporting live
in southern highlands sally jaramillo 8
news now